This episode is the final one in our four-part series that we're calling the future of, dot, dot, dot. We've been exploring how changes the way we live learn, work, and play may shape our health and well-being in years to come. Thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for supporting this episode. The Robert Wood Johnson Foundation is committed to improving health and health equity in the United States. Learn more about them at rwjf.org.
本集是我们四部分系列节目的最后一集，我们将其命名为“未来……”。我们一直在探索改变我们生活、学习、工作和娱乐的方式，将如何塑造我们未来的健康和福祉。感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会对本集节目的支持。罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会致力于改善美国的健康状况和健康公平。请访问 rwjf.org 了解更多信息。
This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Two hours west of Duluth, there's a wide shallow lake called Big Rice Lake. Every summer, once the ice has thawed, the surface of the lake is slowly breached by tall green stalks that grow up and out of the water. By early fall, big rice lake is dotted with canoes full of people there to harvest the grains from those plants. This is where the lake gets its name. These tall, unassuming stems are full of a very special ingredient, wild rice. In my first time actually at at Rice and me and my sister took my grandma and my mother out on the lake and we were going around in circles and they were pointing. I want to go over there, I want to go over there.
这里是 99% Invisible，我是 Roman Mars。在德卢斯以西两小时车程的地方，有一个宽阔而浅的湖泊，叫大米湖（Big Rice Lake）。每年夏天，冰雪融化后，湖面上会慢慢长出高高的绿色茎秆，伸出水面。到了初秋，大米湖上点缀着载满人的独木舟，他们来这里收割这些植物的谷物。这就是湖名的由来。这些高大、不起眼的茎秆里装满了一种非常特殊的成分：野米。我第一次去大米湖时，我和姐姐带着奶奶和妈妈去湖上，我们绕着圈划船，她们指着说：“我想去那边，我想去那边。”
This is Evelyn Belinger, an elder enrolled in the White Earth band, which is the largest of the six bands that make up the Minnesota Chippewa tribe, also known as the Ojibwe people. Evelyn has always loved going out on Big Rice Lake to take part in the harvest. And it's really quiet, you're not going fast, but you can hear when somebody pulls that rice and they got a rhythm and it goes, whoosh, whoosh, you could just hear that rice falling in the boat. The rhythm of it, the song of it. But for the Ojibwe people, this wild rice isn't just a food source. It's a lot more.
这是 Evelyn Belinger，她是白土部落（White Earth band）的一位长者，该部落是组成明尼苏达州奇佩瓦部落（Minnesota Chippewa tribe，也称为奥吉布瓦人/Ojibwe）的六个部落中最大的一个。Evelyn 一直很喜欢去大米湖参加收割。那里非常安静，你划得不快，但你能听到有人采摘野米的声音，他们有自己的节奏，发出“呼——呼——”的声音，你能听到野米落入船中的声音。那是它的节奏，它的歌声。但对于奥吉布瓦人来说，这种野米不仅仅是一种食物来源，它还有更深层的意义。
And it was a gift to the Ojibwe people. It was a gift. The Ojibwe people didn't always live in this part of the Midwest. They used to be based on the East Coast. Then, about a thousand years ago, their elders were visited by the first of seven prophets who guided them. We were told to move from the East Coast because if we didn't, we would be destroyed. When you get a prophecy like that, you don't generally ignore it.
它是送给奥吉布瓦人的礼物。这真的是一份礼物。奥吉布瓦人并不总是居住在中西部的这一地区。他们过去住在东海岸。大约一千年前，七位先知中的第一位拜访了他们的长者，并指引了他们。我们被告知要从东海岸搬走，因为如果我们不走，我们就会被毁灭。当你得到这样的预言时，你通常不会忽视它。
So they packed up and left, looking for a new home. That's reporter Rose Eveleth, host of the podcast Flash Forward. The prophecy said they'd know where to settle when they found the place where the food grows on the water. After centuries of moving around, they wound up in the Great Lakes where they found exactly what they were looking for, in the form of wild rice. The Ojibwe name for this specific type of rice is Minoman, which translates to the Goodberry. The scientific name is Zazania Polustris.
于是他们收拾行囊离开了，寻找新的家园。这是记者 Rose Eveleth，播客 Flash Forward 的主持人。预言说，当他们找到“食物在水上生长”的地方时，他们就会知道在哪里定居。经过几个世纪的迁徙，他们最终来到了五大湖区，在那里，他们以野米的形式找到了他们一直在寻找的东西。奥吉布瓦语中这种特定野米的名称是“Minoman”，翻译过来就是“好浆果”（Goodberry）。其学名是 Zizania palustris。
It's the only grain indigenous to North America, and while it might look and taste a lot like the rice that you might buy at the store, it's actually not closely related to brown or white rice at all. For the Ojibwe people gathering this sacred, prophesized rice is a ritual that carries with it a lot of significance. Not only is Monoman a food source, it's also a way to connect with their ancestors, and a crucial species in the ecosystem. But last year, Monoman took on a new rule, plaintiff in a court case. In August, the Minnesota Department of Natural Resources was sued by Wild Rice.
它是北美唯一的本土谷物，虽然它看起来和吃起来可能很像你在商店里买的米，但它实际上与糙米或白米并没有什么亲缘关系。对于奥吉布瓦人来说，采集这种神圣的、预言中的野米是一种具有重大意义的仪式。Minoman 不仅是一种食物来源，也是与祖先联系的一种方式，更是生态系统中的关键物种。但去年，Minoman 扮演了一个新角色：法庭案件的原告。八月，明尼苏达州自然资源部被野米起诉了。
The case of Monoman V. Minnesota Department of Natural Resources alleges that the Minnesota DNR infringed on the Wild Rice's right to live and thrive. But can Wild Rice sue a state agency? The story answer is yes. This is the story about what might happen if the rice wins. Monoman used to grow wild all over the Great Lakes region, but its populations have declined significantly in the last hundred years due to development, pollution, and climate change. In order to grow properly, the rice needs clean, unpolluted water.
“Minoman 诉明尼苏达州自然资源部”一案指控明尼苏达州自然资源部侵犯了野米生存和繁衍的权利。但野米可以起诉州政府机构吗？故事的答案是肯定的。这是一个关于如果野米胜诉可能会发生什么的故事。Minoman 曾经在整个五大湖地区野生生长，但由于开发、污染和气候变化，其种群在过去一百年中显著减少。为了正常生长，野米需要清洁、无污染的水。
But that's harder and harder to come by these days. A lot of people lost the ability to go out and get either their seasonal harvest for their personal use and order to make some money off of that. That's Frank Vibo, a tribal attorney and a member of the White Earth Band of Ojibwe. Like Evelyn, he has a lifelong connection to the rice and early memories of gathering it. I harvest wild rice, my dad harvesting wild rice, my grandfather harvesting wild rice. I've got the family canoe.
但如今这越来越难实现了。许多人失去了去进行季节性收割的能力，无论是为了个人使用还是为了赚取一些收入。这是 Frank Bibo，一位部落律师，也是白土部落奥吉布瓦人的成员。像 Evelyn 一样，他与野米有着终身的联系，并有着早年采集野米的记忆。我收割野米，我父亲收割野米，我祖父也收割野米。我有家传的独木舟。
I live on a reservation and so we have this other obligation, I guess, is what I would call it. And Frank takes that obligation to protect the rice very, very seriously. Well there are a lot of things hurting Monoman. There's one big obvious threat at the moment. In 2014, a company named Enbridge proposed updating and replacing sections of a crude oil pipeline called Line 3 that goes through Minnesota. But local tribes and environmental activists had questions about just how safe this pipeline really was, and whether pumping more oil through their land was really a good idea.
我住在保留地上，所以我想我们有另一种义务。Frank 非常非常认真地对待保护野米的义务。嗯，有很多事情在伤害 Minoman。目前有一个巨大的、显而易见的威胁。2014 年，一家名为 Enbridge 的公司提议更新和更换一条穿过明尼苏达州的名为“3 号线”（Line 3）的原油管道的部分路段。但当地部落和环保活动人士对这条管道的安全性，以及在他们的土地上输送更多石油是否真的是个好主意提出了质疑。
A pipeline battle brewing in Minnesota, today with the largest show of resistance yet. We will stop Line 3! We love it! with the largest show of resistance yet. We will stop line three! We lost! Activists tried all kinds of tactics to stop line three. They protested and petitioned and lobbied the various environmental agencies to step in. We will no longer stand for our water to be polluted! For our earth to be polluted! That's why we're here today!
明尼苏达州正在酝酿一场管道之战，今天出现了迄今为止规模最大的抗议活动。我们将阻止 3 号线！我们热爱它！这是迄今为止规模最大的抗议活动。我们将阻止 3 号线！我们输了！活动人士尝试了各种策略来阻止 3 号线。他们抗议、请愿，并游说各环保机构介入。我们绝不再容忍我们的水被污染！我们的土地被污染！这就是我们今天在这里的原因！
We're here today because of the time... We reached out to the Minnesota DNR and Enbridge for this story. Both declined to do an interview on the record, but Enbridge did send a statement disputing that the pipeline had negative environmental impacts and saying that they worked with local tribes, including the White Earth Nation, to plan the route for the pipeline. They also say it would bypass certain critical areas in Rice Lake. But many tribal members are not convinced, including Frank. And as he watched things play out, he began developing his own idea for how to stop Line 3 from becoming operational.
我们今天在这里是因为……我们联系了明尼苏达州自然资源部和 Enbridge 寻求置评。双方都拒绝接受正式采访，但 Enbridge 发表了一份声明，否认管道对环境有负面影响，并表示他们与包括白土民族在内的当地部落合作规划了管道路线。他们还表示，管道将绕过大米湖的某些关键区域。但许多部落成员并不相信，包括 Frank。当他看着事态发展时，他开始构思自己的想法，以阻止 3 号线投入运营。
But it wasn't an unusual one. He wanted to represent Wild Rice in a lawsuit against the state of Minnesota. So here I'm holding this card thinking it could work, but I'm the only one. And I've got a zillion attorneys who were like, Frank, this doesn't look like anything. Anybody will even understand his fellow attorneys and friends and activists. They all told him to wait. Wait for the other strategies. Wait and see what might happen. It wasn't until those other avenues felt like they
但这并不是一个寻常的想法。他想在针对明尼苏达州的诉讼中代表野米。所以当时我拿着这张卡片，心想这可能行得通，但我是一个人。我有无数的律师朋友说：“Frank，这看起来什么都不是，没人会理解。”他的律师同行、朋友和活动人士都告诉他要等待。等待其他策略。等待看看会发生什么。直到那些其他途径似乎都走到了死胡同，Frank 才被允许实施他的计划。
were hitting dead ends that Frank was turned loose with his plan. And the funny part is, you know, in Indian country, I'm like a Robin Hood do with this. Frank was developing a legal strategy. He thought instead of playing by the rules of the big national and state agencies, what if you use tribal ideas and tribal court to enforce a relatively new realm of law called the rights of nature? Rights of nature is pretty much what it sounds like, the idea that you could treat nature like a person, legally. Which might sound unusual, but we've used conceptual versions of what a person is in the eyes of the law for quite some time. Corporations, schools, and law firms, for example, are all technically allowed to enter into contracts
有趣的是，你知道，在印第安地区，我就像个罗宾汉。Frank 正在制定一项法律策略。他认为，与其按照大型国家和州机构的规则行事，不如利用部落理念和部落法庭来执行一个相对较新的法律领域，即“自然权利”（Rights of Nature）。自然权利正如其名，即在法律上将自然视为一个人。这听起来可能不寻常，但我们在法律眼中使用“人”的概念版本已经有很长一段时间了。例如，公司、学校和律师事务所，在技术上都被允许像单一的人类一样签订合同。
as if they were singular human beings. And while this environmental version of the concept is relatively new to the American legal system, it has deep roots in indigenous ways of thinking. Well, the rights of nature really is more like ancient law. As Chippewa, and I say Chippewa, because that's what we're called in our treaties as anishinabi or Ojibwe.
虽然这种环境概念版本对美国法律体系来说相对较新，但它在土著思维方式中有着深厚的根源。嗯，自然权利实际上更像是古老的法律。作为奇佩瓦人，我之所以说奇佩瓦人，是因为我们在条约中被称为 Anishinabe 或 Ojibwe。
We have a relationship with all of nature and we refer to them as our relations. The idea of relations isn't purely an Ojibwe concept. It actually shows up in indigenous thinking all over the world. We have a relationship with these plants where, you know, we're human people. There's tree people, there's beaver people, there's deer people, there's bear people, there's salmon people, and the Pacific Northwest, salmon are ancestors as well.
我们与整个自然界都有关系，我们称它们为我们的“亲属”。“亲属”的概念并非纯粹的奥吉布瓦概念。它实际上出现在世界各地的土著思想中。我们与这些植物有某种关系，你知道，我们是人类。还有树木人、海狸人、鹿人、熊人、鲑鱼人，在太平洋西北地区，鲑鱼也是祖先。
And in some ways, they're revered as much more important than humans. This is Miko Albert, a member of the Cherokee Nation and the executive chef of burning cedar indigenous foods. And she says that when it comes to these animal and plant relations, it's not just about using ingredients or respecting certain species. It's deeper than that. You can't think of it from a colonized standpoint and think like, okay, it's some grass, grow the grass somewhere else. This is their relative, this is the reason their people exist. It's not just grass, it's so much bigger than that.
在某些方面，它们被尊崇为比人类更重要。这是 Miko Albert，切罗基民族成员，也是 Burning Cedar Indigenous Foods 的行政主厨。她说，当谈到这些动物和植物亲属时，这不仅仅是关于使用食材或尊重某些物种。它比这更深。你不能从殖民者的角度去思考，觉得“好吧，这只是一些草，在别处种草就行了”。这是他们的亲属，这是他们民族存在的原因。这不仅仅是草，它比那宏大得多。
So from a Māori perspective, we've always known and believed that we are of the land, that we are part of this place, that the lands and the mountains, the sky, the earth are our ancestors, and that through that we have our responsibilities to care and to nourish the lands and the waters around us. That's just Centre Ruru, a professor of law at the University of Otago in New Zealand. For Jocenta, giving nature legal rights isn't just about trying to protect nature.
所以从毛利人的角度来看，我们一直知道并相信我们来自土地，我们是这个地方的一部分，土地、山脉、天空、大地都是我们的祖先，通过这一点，我们有责任照顾和滋养我们周围的土地和水域。这是新西兰奥塔哥大学法学教授 Jacinta Ruru。对于 Jacinta 来说，赋予自然法律权利不仅仅是为了保护自然。
It's also about legally validating this indigenous way of thinking. By writing it into law, you're saying that you think nature's personhood is as valid as a tax law. In some places, like New Zealand, these rules have been more about making a gesture of recognition than about stopping an imminent environmental threat. In 2014, the country returned an already protected reserve to the Toohoi people for them to manage. Those lanes are incredibly
这也是为了在法律上验证这种土著思维方式。通过将其写入法律，你是在说你认为自然的“人格”与税法一样有效。在一些地方，比如新西兰，这些规则更多是作为一种认可的姿态，而不是为了阻止迫在眉睫的环境威胁。2014 年，该国将一个已经受到保护的保护区归还给图霍伊人（Tuhoe）进行管理。那些土地对图霍伊人的身份认同来说极其重要，
important to the identity of Toohoi, who they are and who they will always be, as entirely connected into those lands and those waters. These lands weren't threatened. Nobody was trying to build a pipeline through them or cut down the trees. The decision was about showing that Indigenous law and land management was worthy of the country's respect and trust. It is a wonderful way to be able to show to us as New Zealanders that the sky is not going to fall in
他们是谁，他们将永远是谁，都与那些土地和水域完全相连。这些土地并没有受到威胁。没有人试图在它们中间修建管道或砍伐树木。这一决定是为了表明土著法律和土地管理值得国家的尊重和信任。这是一种美妙的方式，向我们新西兰人展示，如果我们承认毛利人照顾土地和水域的方式，天不会塌下来，
that the world is not going to end if we recognise a Māori way of caring for lands and waters. But in other parts of the world, environmental activists are hoping to move past symbolism and use the rights of nature argument as a legal weapon to stop deforestation or pollution. Yeah, I don't have much patience to the symbolic kind of stuff anymore. This is Thomas Lindsay, the senior legal counsel for the Center for Democratic and Environmental Rights.
世界也不会终结。但在世界其他地方，环保活动人士希望超越象征意义，利用自然权利的论点作为法律武器来阻止森林砍伐或污染。是的，我对那种象征性的东西已经没有多少耐心了。这是 Thomas Linzey，民主与环境权利中心（Center for Democratic and Environmental Rights）的高级法律顾问。
It's almost like passing a non-binding resolution or passing resolution says this is Earth date. It really passed that now. Tell me, spent the early part of his career trying to play by the book, working to protect the environment through all the usual regulations and laws. But he said time and time again, he watched as powerful industry players got what they wanted no matter what the rule said. And there was one case in particular, he said, that really made him reconsider the point of trying to go through the systems that exist. It was a case in Northern Pennsylvania dealing with a wood chip mill. The wood chip mills neighbors started to complain about the pollution from the mill,
这几乎就像通过一项不具约束力的决议，或者通过一项说“今天是地球日”的决议。这真的通过了。告诉我，他职业生涯的早期都在试图按部就班，通过所有常规的法规和法律来保护环境。但他表示，他一次又一次地看到，无论规则怎么说，强大的行业参与者总能得到他们想要的。他说，有一个案例特别让他重新思考通过现有系统解决问题的意义。那是宾夕法尼亚州北部一个关于木片加工厂的案例。木片加工厂的邻居开始抱怨工厂的污染，
and Thomas and his colleagues found out that the mill wasn't permitted to operate at all. This should have been easy. The mill was operating without a permit, polluting the environment, and harming the local residents. So it should be shut down, right? And I guess to our chagriner, wonder, the state agency retroactively permitted the wood chip operation by fax. So they faxed a permit to the corporation running the wood chip operation that had a retro active permit at it, which basically legalized all their past activities associated with the wood chip mill. So
Thomas 和他的同事发现，该工厂根本没有运营许可。这本该很容易解决。工厂在没有许可证的情况下运营，污染环境，伤害当地居民。所以它应该被关闭，对吧？但我猜令我们懊恼和惊讶的是，州政府机构通过传真追溯性地批准了该木片加工业务。他们给经营木片加工业务的公司传真了一份许可证，上面有一个追溯性的许可日期，这基本上使他们过去与木片加工厂相关的所有活动合法化了。所以
there were a number of those kinds of experiences over the years, which showed us at least that the regulatory system was really more of a hamster wheel that was set up purposefully for people to run around and around. So instead of running on the hamster wheel, Thomas got involved in the wave of lawyers trying to use the idea of environmental personhood to protect specific spaces legally. His organization, the Center for Democratic and Environmental Rights, has been involved in implementing constitutional amendments and laws all over the world. Thanks to CDER and other rights of nature activists, there are now movements in Mexico, Spain, Brazil, India,
多年来有许多这样的经历，这至少向我们表明，监管体系实际上更像是一个仓鼠轮，是专门为人们在里面跑来跑去而设置的。因此，Thomas 没有在仓鼠轮上奔跑，而是加入了一群试图利用环境人格理念在法律上保护特定空间的律师行列。他的组织，民主与环境权利中心，参与了世界各地的宪法修正案和法律的实施。感谢 CDER 和其他自然权利活动人士，现在墨西哥、西班牙、巴西、印度、
Bolivia and more. When the Uttarakhand High Court is declared the Ganga Niyamuna's living entities bestowing on them, the same legal rights as a person, thus making the river the world's second to get such a status. The New Zealand parliament has passed a bill recognizing the Walnut-Newy River as a living entity to the same legal rights as a person. Even in the United States, there have been attempts at using this legal framework to protect land from pollution and degradation.
玻利维亚等地都有了相关运动。当北阿坎德邦高等法院宣布恒河和亚穆纳河为“活体”，赋予它们与人相同的法律权利时，这条河流成为世界上第二个获得此类地位的河流。新西兰议会通过了一项法案，承认旺格努伊河（Whanganui River）为具有与人相同法律权利的活体。即使在美国，也有尝试利用这一法律框架来保护土地免受污染和退化。
The Colorado River ecosystem versus the state of Colorado. That's right, the entire river system, all 1,500 miles of it from Colorado to California, is the plaintiff. A Native American tribe has granted personhood to a river in Northern California, making it the first known river in North America to have the same legal rights as a human. Reboat happening in Ohio right now is testing the waters of an idea to give a lake legal rights like people have. Yep, those behind the Lake Erie bill of rights say it'll protect it from pollution and potential algae blooms, but those against it say it could be costly for the whole region. But while the concept of rights of nature is catching on all over the world, there is a
科罗拉多河生态系统诉科罗拉多州。没错，整个河流系统，从科罗拉多州到加利福尼亚州全长 1500 英里，都是原告。一个美洲原住民部落授予了北加州一条河流人格权，使其成为北美已知的第一个拥有与人类相同法律权利的河流。俄亥俄州正在发生的事情正在测试赋予湖泊像人一样法律权利的想法。是的，伊利湖权利法案（Lake Erie Bill of Rights）的支持者表示，这将保护它免受污染和潜在的藻类爆发，但反对者表示，这可能会给整个地区带来高昂的成本。但虽然自然权利的概念在世界各地流行起来，但
difference between the idea getting popular and the idea actually working. The one place that advocates can point to where these laws have made clear impact is Ecuador, where Thomas and his collaborators help pass a rights of nature constitutional amendment back in 2008. A few months ago, an Ecuadorian court ruled by mining in the
想法的流行与想法的实际运作之间存在差异。倡导者可以指出的唯一一个这些法律产生了明确影响的地方是厄瓜多尔，Thomas 和他的合作者在那里帮助通过了 2008 年的自然权利宪法修正案。几个月前，厄瓜多尔法院裁定在
Los Angeles protected forests would violate the rights of nature and shouldn't be permitted. But in the United States, this strategy has yet to really work. In the case of Lake Erie, a court quickly overturned the vote and rendered the charter amendment useless. There are lawsuits working their way through the systems in Florida and Seattle, but nothing has really come of them yet. Which brings us back to the wild rice. Frank Bebo, the tribal attorney for the White Earth Band, met Thomas years ago when Thomas came out to do a presentation on rights of nature in Indian country.
洛杉矶保护林（Los Angeles protected forests）进行的采矿活动将违反自然权利，不应被允许。但在美国，这一策略尚未真正奏效。在伊利湖一案中，法院迅速推翻了投票结果，使宪章修正案失效。佛罗里达州和西雅图的系统中也有诉讼正在进行，但目前还没有什么结果。这把我们带回了野米。白土部落的部落律师 Frank Bibo 多年前在 Thomas 来印第安地区进行自然权利演讲时认识了他。
You know, we talked for two, three hours about what they were doing with rights of nature. And during break time, my professor kind of pulled Thomas, and he said, you know, we talked for two, three hours about what they were doing with rights and nature and during break time my professor Kind of pulled Thomas side and he says, you know You're talking about rights of nature the way you present it to white people and the other parts of the United States for their city or state laws and ordinances These are Indians and they already have a right to nature You know, it's a question of how you harness it and manage it So in 2017 Frank Bibo came to us and we started having a conversation with him about what it might look like to apply these rights or nature concepts to wild rice. Working together, Frank and Thomas brought the Monoman case, which is currently making
你知道，我们谈了两个、三个小时关于他们正在用自然权利做什么。在休息时间，我的教授把 Thomas 拉到一边，他说，你知道，你谈论自然权利的方式是你向白人以及美国其他地区展示的方式，为了他们的城市或州法律和条例。这些人是印第安人，他们已经拥有了自然权利。你知道，这是一个如何利用和管理它的问题。所以 2017 年，Frank Bibo 来找我们，我们开始与他讨论将这些自然权利概念应用于野米会是什么样子。通过合作，Frank 和 Thomas 提起了 Minoman 案，该案目前正在
its way through the legal system. It faces various hurdles, which we'll get into. But Frank has faith that this case could be the thing that turns the tide on the rights of nature movement here in the US. And I think we're gonna be the tip of the spear on environmental protection in North America and particularly in the United States. Frank is confident for a couple of reasons.
通过法律体系。它面临着各种障碍，我们稍后会谈到。但 Frank 相信，这个案件可能成为在美国扭转自然权利运动局势的关键。我认为我们将成为北美，特别是美国环境保护的先锋。Frank 充满信心有两个原因。
First, the tribe already has a rights of nature law in place. In 2018, with the help of Thomas and his organization, the White Earth Band of the Chippewa Nation adopted something called the rights of the Minoman, a tribal law that said that wild rice had legal rights. And then the question was, well, how do we actually enforce this? And the opportunity to enforce came about because of the proposal to put in this line three tar sands oil pipeline by Enbridge Corporation. Not only do they have this recent tribal law on their side, they also have something much
首先，该部落已经有了自然权利法。2018 年，在 Thomas 和他的组织的帮助下，奇佩瓦民族白土部落通过了所谓的“Minoman 权利”，这是一项部落法律，规定野米拥有法律权利。接下来的问题是，我们该如何真正执行它？而执行的机会是因为 Enbridge 公司提议修建这条 3 号线焦油砂油管道。他们不仅有这项最近的部落法律支持，他们还有更
older to point to. In our 1837 treaty, the words wild rice themselves appear. When America started its push for expanding and colonizing what's now considered the United States, they did so in part by making agreements with the people who already lived on that land. Between 1778 and 1871, the U.S. government signed hundreds of treaties offering all kinds of arrangements with local tribes, exchanging promises of peace and protection for land, resources, access to waterways, and more. According to the U.S. Constitution, these treaties are the supreme ruler of all rules.
古老的东西可以指引。在我们的 1837 年条约中，出现了“野米”这两个字。当美国开始推动扩张和殖民现在被认为是美国的土地时，他们部分是通过与已经居住在那片土地上的人民达成协议来做到的。在 1778 年至 1871 年间，美国政府签署了数百项条约，与当地部落达成各种安排，以和平与保护的承诺换取土地、资源、水道使用权等。根据美国宪法，这些条约是所有规则中的最高规则。
That's literally what the Constitution says. It says that, quote, all treaties made or which shall be made under the authority of the United States shall be the supreme law of the land. And in the treaty with the White Earth Band, wild rice is specifically named as something the tribe gets to keep. The rice gets protected. We retain the rights to hunt fishing gather wild rice on the lands, lakes, and rivers in the territory being seeded. And so in that technical sense, the words wild rice are the supreme law of the land. Now, the United States doesn't have a great history of keeping the promises made in these treaties, but in the last few years, the US Supreme Court has started respecting these agreements more and more,
这字面上就是宪法所说的。它说，引用：“所有根据美国权力已经缔结或将要缔结的条约，均应为国家的最高法律。”而在与白土部落的条约中，野米被明确命名为部落有权保留的东西。野米受到保护。我们保留在割让领土内的土地、湖泊和河流上狩猎、捕鱼和采集野米的权利。因此，从技术意义上讲，“野米”这两个字是国家的最高法律。现在，美国在遵守这些条约所作承诺方面并没有很好的历史，但在过去几年里，美国最高法院开始越来越尊重这些协议，
rather than ignoring them. So the tribe has a right-signature law in place. It has a treaty to point to, and the final reason Frank is confident is because past cases happened in state or federal court, but here he's specifically filing in tribal court. Tribes in the United States are complicated legal entities. They're a little bit like states, but they're not technically states, and tribal law is its own entire legal expertise. Many tribes have
而不是忽视它们。所以部落有自然权利法，有条约可以指引，而 Frank 充满信心的最后一个原因是，过去的案件发生在州或联邦法院，但在这里，他特别是在部落法庭提起诉讼。美国的部落是复杂的法律实体。它们有点像州，但技术上不是州，部落法律有其独特的法律专业知识。许多部落有
their own courts, but that development is relatively new. For the most part, most tribal courts have been around 20 or 25 years, and that means there isn't a body of case law in federal courts that says what we can and can't do in tribal court. Not only are these tribal courts fairly new, they've also never been used this way. Tribal courts generally hear cases about divorces and custody hearings and criminal offenses. And so this means that Frank's strategy is an untested legal gambit. It's not clear yet if it will work. Now Frank is the first one to admit that this strategy might seem a little confusing or strange. In fact, he says it's weird for both sides.
自己的法庭，但这种发展相对较新。在大多数情况下，大多数部落法庭存在了大约 20 或 25 年，这意味着联邦法院中没有一套判例法来规定我们在部落法庭中能做什么和不能做什么。这些部落法庭不仅相当新，而且从未以这种方式使用过。部落法庭通常审理关于离婚、监护权听证会和刑事犯罪的案件。这意味着 Frank 的策略是一场未经测试的法律博弈。目前还不清楚它是否会奏效。现在 Frank 是第一个承认这种策略可能看起来有点令人困惑或奇怪的人。事实上，他说这对双方来说都很奇怪。
Those who aren't indigenous and don't connect the idea of nature as a relative, sometimes find the whole concept odd. And indigenous people often find it baffling that it takes all these legal shenanigans to officially declare something that they find so very obvious. It's very clear. It's very simple. It's just ancient law. And that's what makes it such a comedy in Indian country because it's like wild rice
那些不是土著且不将自然视为亲属的人，有时会觉得整个概念很奇怪。而土著人民往往感到困惑，为什么需要所有这些法律花招来正式宣布一件他们认为如此显而易见的事情。这非常清楚。这非常简单。这只是古老的法律。这就是为什么它在印第安地区成了一场闹剧，因为这就像野米
is so in the DNR. How about that? That's how stupid law can be. Right now, everybody is waiting to hear what two different sets of judges are going to decide. One case in tribal court and one in federal court. Both of those cases right now hinge entirely on the question of jurisdiction.
在自然资源部（DNR）里。那又怎样？法律可以有多愚蠢。现在，每个人都在等待听取两组不同的法官将做出什么决定。一个案件在部落法庭，一个在联邦法院。这两个案件目前完全取决于管辖权的问题。
Jurisdiction is a little confusing at different times and what I try to tell people most of the time it just means who has the right to decide. The Minnesota Department of Natural Resources is arguing that the case should not be heard in White Earth Tribal Court at all, in part because doing so would apply tribal law to actions taken outside the reservation. And in March, in a move that surprised Frank and Thomas, the White Earth Court of Appeals agreed with that argument. Because Line 3 doesn't technically pass through the reservation,
管辖权在不同时间有点令人困惑，我通常告诉人们，它只是意味着谁有权决定。明尼苏达州自然资源部辩称，该案件根本不应该在白土部落法庭审理，部分原因是这样做会将部落法律应用于保留地之外采取的行动。三月，在一个让 Frank 和 Thomas 感到惊讶的举动中，白土上诉法院同意了这一论点。因为 3 号线在技术上并没有穿过保留地，
they argued that the White Earth Band had no say in what went on, even if the impact of Line 3 can be seen on the reservation. Obviously, Frank disagrees. He is asked the Appeals Court to reconsider, and they're now waiting on that decision. If the appeals courts side with Frank and Thomas, and they get to keep going, it's worth considering what would happen next, because the implications would be big. Well, first, it's possible that there could be even more appeals that drag on even longer. But if they get through those, then they get to try the case in court officially with arguments and lots more documents filed back and forth.
他们辩称，白土部落对发生的事情没有发言权，即使 3 号线的影响可以在保留地上看到。显然，Frank 不同意。他已要求上诉法院重新考虑，他们现在正在等待该决定。如果上诉法院站在 Frank 和 Thomas 一边，他们得以继续进行，那么考虑接下来会发生什么就很有意义了，因为影响将是巨大的。嗯，首先，可能会有更多的上诉拖得更久。但如果他们通过了这些，那么他们就可以正式在法庭上审理此案，进行辩论并提交更多文件。
And if after all of that, they actually win and the tribal court rules against the Minnesota Department of Natural Resources, then things get really interesting. And I think that's gonna be like gasoline and matches. If Wild Rice prevails in this case, it could mean a few things for both the region and the nation. The most obvious change would be to the local area. It would be a blow to the continued use of the Line 3 pipeline, which has been operational since October of last year.
如果在那之后，他们真的赢了，部落法庭做出了不利于明尼苏达州自然资源部的裁决，那么事情就变得非常有趣了。我想那就像汽油和火柴。如果野米在此案中胜诉，这对该地区和全国都可能意味着几件事。最明显的变化将是当地。这将是对 3 号线管道持续使用的打击，该管道自去年 10 月以来一直处于运营状态。
A court order could, hypothetically, force Enbridge to shut the whole thing down. But the reason that Frank and Thomas are both excited about this particular case is because it could change the ways that land is used and developed much more broadly. Well, the real question is what are you trying to protect while I'm trying to protect wild rice, and by protecting wild rice, wild rice will protect everything else? Like many tribes, the reservation that the White Earth Band currently occupies is a tiny fraction of the land that their treaty with the United States government actually covers. Over the years, the U.S. pushed tribal residents onto smaller and smaller plots, chipping away at their
法院命令理论上可以迫使 Enbridge 关闭整个项目。但 Frank 和 Thomas 对这个特定案件感到兴奋的原因是，它可以更广泛地改变土地的使用和开发方式。嗯，真正的问题是你试图保护什么？我试图保护野米，通过保护野米，野米将保护其他一切。像许多部落一样，白土部落目前占据的保留地只是他们与美国政府条约实际覆盖的土地的一小部分。多年来，美国将部落居民赶到越来越小的地块上，蚕食了他们的
ancestral homes. But the original treaties often cover vast swaths of land. And one of the things that Frank and the White Earth Band is asking for in their case is for a co-permitting agreement for new construction. In other words, if anybody wants to build something like a pipeline, the tribe would have to sign off on it, not just on present day reservation land, but for all the land that the original Ojibwe treaties covered. And that is a lot of land. We're talking about something like 11 million acres in total. And so the reason why this case has so much potential is that if it's successful, it not only validates this kind of tribal rights of nature concept about tribes, fascinarites
祖居地。但最初的条约通常覆盖大片土地。Frank 和白土部落在案件中要求的一件事是为新建筑达成共同许可协议。换句话说，如果有人想建造像管道这样的东西，部落必须签字同意，不仅是在现有的保留地土地上，而且是针对最初奥吉布瓦条约覆盖的所有土地。那可是很大一片土地。我们谈论的是总共约 1100 万英亩的土地。所以这个案件之所以有如此大的潜力，是因为如果它成功了，它不仅验证了这种关于部落的自然权利概念，
and nature laws, but it also would allow tribes in the United States to reach into all of those treaty lands to have control over permits issued on those lands. And it doesn't stop at those measly 11 million acres of land. What Thomas and Frank really hope is that if this case succeeds, they will be on their way to making the idea of environmental personhood
而且它还将允许美国的部落触及所有这些条约土地，从而对在这些土地上签发的许可证拥有控制权。而且它并没有止步于那区区 1100 万英亩土地。Thomas 和 Frank 真正希望的是，如果这个案件成功，他们将走上让环境人格理念
a thing all over the United States. And that would change laws and save ecosystems, but it might also change something a lot more fundamental. Because in a lot of ways, this idea that nature has rights like a person might, is the complete opposite of a lot of modern economic thinking about nature. And I heard from back to Sir Francis Bacon in England who said, you know, the job of civilization is to torture nature on a rack to extract your secrets. Okay, so technically this was a quote from a different fancy pants European scholar.
在美国各地普及的道路。这将改变法律并拯救生态系统，但它也可能改变一些更根本的东西。因为在很多方面，这种自然像人一样拥有权利的想法，与许多关于自然的现代经济思维完全相反。我听过弗朗西斯·培根爵士在英国说过，你知道，文明的工作是在架子上折磨自然以提取你的秘密。好吧，从技术上讲，这是另一位花哨的欧洲学者的名言。
It was Gottfried Wilhelm Liebnitz who said this, not Francis Bacon, but Liebnitz was talking about bacon when he said it, so... The point is, is that if the concept of the rights of nature really takes off in law, it means reconsidering more than just one pipeline or one construction project. The whole story needs to change. The source code needs to change. The DNA needs to be altered. The only way that happens is when massive numbers of people begin to move into these institutions
是戈特弗里德·威廉·莱布尼茨（Gottfried Wilhelm Leibniz）说了这句话，而不是弗朗西斯·培根，但莱布尼茨在说这句话时是在谈论培根，所以……重点是，如果自然权利的概念在法律上真正流行起来，这意味着要重新考虑的不仅仅是一条管道或一个建设项目。整个故事需要改变。源代码需要改变。DNA 需要被改变。唯一发生这种情况的方法是当大量的人开始进入这些机构，
to, in essence, change their DNA. That's part of the idea behind rights of nature. It's not quite there yet, but as a movement that I think is what it's aiming towards is changing how everything works. And with a shift like that comes some big questions. For example, if nature gets the right to live and thrive, like a person might, then can you just never build anything again? Thomas gets this question a lot. He told me that once he was up in New Hampshire, trying to convince some skeptics
本质上改变它们的 DNA。这就是自然权利背后的部分想法。它还没有完全实现，但作为一场运动，我认为它的目标是改变一切运作的方式。随着这种转变，出现了一些大问题。例如，如果自然像人一样拥有生存和繁衍的权利，那么你是否就永远不能再建造任何东西了？Thomas 经常遇到这个问题。他告诉我，有一次他在新罕布什尔州，试图说服一些怀疑论者，
that a couple of local rights of nature laws weren't going to stop development altogether. Some guy got up in the back and he said, well, if we pass this, it means we can't shoot squirrels anymore here in the municipality. And so I prepared to answer his question, but some old guy, his friend got up in the back and he said, no, Mel, what it means is that we can't shoot all the squirrels. The idea here isn't to actually protect each grain of rice or salmon or squirrel as if it's a human being.
当地的几项自然权利法律并不会完全阻止开发。后面有个家伙站起来说：“好吧，如果我们通过了这个，这意味着我们在这里的市政当局就不能再射杀松鼠了。”所以我准备回答他的问题，但后面有个老家伙，他的朋友站起来说：“不，Mel，它的意思是，我们不能把松鼠全部射杀。”这里的想法并不是真的要保护每一粒米、每一条鲑鱼或每一只松鼠，就好像它是人类一样。
You can still hunt or fish or build, as long as overall, it doesn't infringe on the right of the natural system to thrive. So if a forest is protected, it doesn't mean you can't cut down a tree. It just means you can't cause damage to the ecosystem by taking out so many of the trees that the entire ecosystem folds. The actual specifics of these debates will always be tricky. Who is to say whether the ocean wants an offshore wind farm that might overall decrease global warming?
你仍然可以狩猎、捕鱼或建造，只要总体上它不侵犯自然系统繁衍的权利。所以如果一片森林受到保护，并不意味着你不能砍伐一棵树。它只是意味着你不能通过砍伐太多的树木导致整个生态系统崩溃来破坏生态系统。这些辩论的具体细节总是很棘手。谁能说海洋是否想要一个可能会降低全球变暖的离岸风电场？
Who gets to decide if the river would rather have a hydroelectric dam or not? In other words, who speaks for the trees? Other than the Lorax, the answer right now is frustratingly vague and that it depends on the situation. In cases of tribal treaties, the indigenous communities would take on that role, but that's not always the case. A lawsuit currently awaiting hearing in Florida, for example, has a wetland, assuming a developer. There's no treaty involved and no tribe driving the effort.
谁来决定河流是否更愿意拥有水电大坝？换句话说，谁为树木代言？除了 Lorax，目前的答案令人沮丧地模糊，这取决于具体情况。在部落条约的情况下，土著社区将承担这一角色，但这并非总是如此。例如，佛罗里达州目前等待听证的一起诉讼中，有一片湿地起诉了一家开发商。没有涉及条约，也没有部落推动这项工作。
You want more people, not less representing ecosystems because you want more of these cases brought, not less, but folks that have some kind of relationship to the ecosystem itself. It's important for those folks to be recognized as guardians or plaintiffs in this case. Extending person like rights to a non-person is always going to be fraught. There will always be opportunities for abuse here. The process could be hijacked by nimbis. We could end up with strange and complicated legal cases
你想要更多的人，而不是更少的人代表生态系统，因为你希望提起更多这样的案件，而不是更少，但那些与生态系统本身有某种关系的人。让这些人被承认为监护人或原告是很重要的。将类似人的权利扩展到非人身上总是充满风险。这里总会有被滥用的机会。这个过程可能会被邻避主义者（NIMBYs）劫持。我们最终可能会得到奇怪而复杂的法律案件，
that make people scratch their heads and wonder what all these lawyers are doing exactly. You know, a lot itself is a figment. It's an artificial creation. And sure, the rights of nature argument is still a gamble, but for Thomas and Frank, it's worth trying. It's kind of like when you have a pair of glasses on your table and the arms a little loose and you look over and you've got a pair of scissors on the table and you try to tighten
让人们抓耳挠腮，想知道这些律师到底在做什么。你知道，法律本身就是一个虚构。它是一个人为的创造。当然，自然权利的论点仍然是一场赌博，但对于 Thomas 和 Frank 来说，这是值得尝试的。这有点像当你桌上有一副眼镜，镜腿有点松，你抬头看到桌上有一把剪刀，你试着拧紧
that little screw. You know, it's not the right tool, but it can work. Right now the Monomenon Cakes is still up in the air, but Frank is already helping other tribes consider a similar strategy. In Seattle, the Soxuietal tribe has found a case in tribal court seeking to protect salmon. This summer, the rice will grow on the lakes again, and the boats will head out the way they always have. Here's Evelyn Bellinger again. I was looking back. I have a picture here of wild rice when they were rice in when I was a kid. The photo shows a mass of boats and people. Some of the boats were empty while others are full of
那个小螺丝。你知道，这不是正确的工具，但它能起作用。目前 Minoman 案仍然悬而未决，但 Frank 已经在帮助其他部落考虑类似的策略。在西雅图，Soxuietal 部落已经在部落法庭提起诉讼，寻求保护鲑鱼。今年夏天，野米将再次在湖泊上生长，船只将像往常一样出发。这是 Evelyn Bellinger。我回头看。我这里有一张野米的照片，是我小时候收割时的照片。照片显示了一大群船只和人。有些船是空的，而另一些则装满了
bags of rice. Cars line the road as far as the eye can see. They had wooden boats. It was taken in 1963, so I was about 10 years old. It was taken in 1963, so I was about 10 years old. And it was just everybody was so involved with the harvesting the rice. And I remember I could stand outside and I could hear the neighbors. You know, they were all getting ready to start racing. Everybody was happy, talking, and all that. Those are some of my best memories. I guess to me it was always kind of like connecting with our ancestors because they've
袋装的野米。汽车沿着道路排开，一眼望不到头。他们有木船。那是 1963 年拍的，所以我当时大约 10 岁。那是 1963 年拍的，所以我当时大约 10 岁。每个人都非常投入地收割野米。我记得我可以站在外面，听到邻居们的声音。你知道，他们都在准备开始收割。每个人都很开心，在交谈，诸如此类。这些是我最美好的回忆。我想对我来说，这总是像与我们的祖先联系，因为他们
always done this before us. I just kind of felt that connection is quiet, quiet out there and I just always used to get that urge I want to go. And perhaps by the time Evelyn's grandchildren go out on the lake, the rice will have officially presented its case in court. And when they go out to gather it, they might get to congratulate it on a job well done. Coming up after the break, we tease out some of the more complicated implications of environmental personhood. Like, could a river sue a person? And could that person sue a river? Stay with us.
在我们之前一直这样做。我只是觉得那种联系很安静，在外面很安静，我总是有一种冲动，我想去。也许当 Evelyn 的孙辈去湖上时，野米将正式在法庭上陈述其案件。当他们去采集它时，他们也许能祝贺它出色地完成了工作。休息后回来，我们将梳理一些关于环境人格更复杂的含义。比如，河流可以起诉一个人吗？那个人可以起诉河流吗？请继续收听。
Support for this four part series exploring the future of health and wellbeing comes from the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, which is committed to improving health and health equity in the United States. Knowing that the healthy, equitable future we all deserve won't simply arrive. RWJF is exploring how new technologies, scientific discoveries, cultural shifts, and unforeseen events like those in today's story may shape our lives in years to come. Through these explorations, their learning what emerging trends or cutting-edge ideas can help us build a future that provides every individual with a fair and just opportunity to thrive, no matter who they are, where they live,
本系列节目共四集，旨在探索健康与福祉的未来，由罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会（RWJF）赞助播出。该基金会致力于改善美国的健康状况及健康公平性。我们深知，我们应得的健康、公平的未来不会凭空到来。RWJF 正在探索新技术、科学发现、文化变迁以及像今天故事中那样不可预见的事件，将如何塑造我们未来的生活。通过这些探索，他们正在了解哪些新兴趋势或前沿理念，能够帮助我们构建一个未来，让每个人，无论其身份、居住地，
or how much money they have. So if you like thinking about the future of things, visit rwjf.org slash pioneering ideas to learn more and apply for a grant from the pioneering ideas for an equitable future team. Over the years, this team has funded projects that help nurses tap into their maker mentality to improve care at the bedside, supported gig economy workers to redefine what good work looks like, equipped architects to design buildings where human contact flourishes, encouraged product designers to create
或经济状况如何，都能获得公平公正的发展机会。因此，如果您喜欢思考事物的未来，请访问 rwjf.org/pioneering-ideas，了解更多信息并向“为公平未来而开拓的理念”团队申请资助。多年来，该团队资助的项目包括：帮助护士利用创客思维改善床边护理，支持零工经济工作者重新定义“好工作”的内涵，装备建筑师设计促进人际交往的建筑，鼓励产品设计师创造
humane technology, and even publish a collection of short stories to help people imagine a healthier future. Designers, scientists, artists, toy makers, researchers, librarians, if you're listening to this show, I have a sneaking suspicion. You have a cutting edge idea or two worth sharing. Get all the details at rwjf.org slash pioneering ideas. So Rose, you make a podcast called Flash Forward, which is all about the future,
人性化的技术，甚至出版了一系列短篇小说来帮助人们构想更健康的未来。设计师、科学家、艺术家、玩具制造商、研究人员、图书管理员，如果您正在收听这个节目，我有一种预感，您可能有一两个值得分享的前沿想法。请在 rwjf.org/pioneering-ideas 获取所有详细信息。那么，Rose，你制作了一个名为《Flash Forward》的播客，专门探讨未来，
which means you spend a lot of time thinking about what might happen down the line. And we talked about this in the episode about the Monoman case and how this might impact line three and even environmental policy more generally. But I'm wondering if this goes any further. I mean, in this future, could I be sued by a river, for example? Yeah, so the short answer to that question is, yes, you, Roman Mars, could hypothetically be sued by a river. If you were, say, dumping stuff into a river that you were not supposed to be,
这意味着你花了很多时间思考未来可能会发生什么。我们在关于 Monoman 案件的那一集中讨论过这个问题，以及它可能如何影响 3 号线（Line 3）乃至更广泛的环境政策。但我很好奇，这是否会走得更远？我的意思是，在未来，我会被一条河流起诉吗？是的，简单回答你的问题，是的，你，Roman Mars，理论上可能会被一条河流起诉。如果你，比如说，往一条你不该倾倒东西的河流里倾倒东西，
and the river's legal representatives decided to bring a case against you, that is in fact a possible future. So Russian river V Roman Mars is a hypothetically possible future case. Okay, I mean, I'm trying to think of like what this could possibly lead to is like, do I have to get river insurance or, you know, like things like that beyond this. But let's just assume that me as an individual, A, I wouldn't do that ever. Just to be clear. Please believe me.
而河流的法律代表决定对你提起诉讼，这确实是一个可能的未来。所以，俄罗斯河诉 Roman Mars 是一个理论上可能的未来案件。好吧，我的意思是，我试图思考这可能会导致什么，比如，我是否需要购买河流保险，或者，你知道，除了这些之外还有什么。但让我们假设作为一个个体，A，我永远不会那样做。为了澄清一下，请相信我。
I would just, I would never have flew to river. But, you know, the damage one person can do to a river, it's pretty limited. Like, we're really talking about industry and things like that. Yeah, right. I mean, even if you and I would never besmirch you to suggest this, but even if you were to throw a wrapper into the river, right, like, that is not worth the time and resources that would be required to take this to court. So I think the likelihood of this
我绝对、绝对不会污染河流。但是，你知道，一个人对河流造成的损害是非常有限的。我们真正谈论的是工业等等。是的，没错。我的意思是，即使你和我——我绝不会诋毁你而暗示这一点——但即使你往河里扔了一个包装纸，对吧，那也不值得为此花费时间和资源去打官司。所以我认为这种情况
being used against singular individuals, you Roman Mars, me, whatever it is, is very low. The point here is to go after big ticket items, pipelines, mining, oil refining, fracking, all the stuff that you see in the news as kind of like those big players. Right. But like, you know, if this legal framework is set up, I could be sued by a river.
被用来针对个人，你 Roman Mars，我，或者其他任何人，可能性非常低。这里的重点是针对大项目，管道、采矿、炼油、水力压裂，所有你在新闻中看到的那些大玩家。没错。但是，你知道，如果这个法律框架建立起来，我确实可能被一条河流起诉。
I mean, that's just who gets, you know, chosen to be sued is the discretion of the people who are suing people. Yeah, yeah. And I think it's actually interesting that you picked rivers as the example here, because they are sort of one of the trickier types of environmental cases at play when we talk about rights of nature. Rivers famously flow, right? They are often quite long, and they often cross state and even national borders. And this was Frank's issue with the idea of rights of nature at the beginning as well. I was reluctant at first working with Tom on rights of a river because the Mississippi river has probably 30 different water controls associated with
我的意思是，谁被选中起诉是由起诉人决定的。是的，是的。而且我觉得你选择河流作为例子很有趣，因为当我们谈论自然权利时，它们是环境案件中最棘手的一类。众所周知，河流是流动的，对吧？它们通常很长，而且经常跨越州界甚至国界。这也是 Frank 在一开始对自然权利概念的疑虑。我起初不愿与 Tom 合作处理河流权利问题，因为密西西比河可能有 30 种不同的水控制措施，与
the upper Mississippi river reservoir system. Yeah, a river is a complicated entity and it touches a lot of different places and jurisdictions. And it makes me wonder like, okay, if I were to pollute a river up here in Oakland to keep this hypothetical going, please understand, I would never pollute a river rose, you have to understand. I'm just filing this away for a future lawsuit that I'm going to file against you when you pollute a river. Okay. Okay.
上密西西比河水库系统相关。是的，河流是一个复杂的实体，它触及许多不同的地方和司法管辖区。这让我不禁想，好吧，如果我在奥克兰这里污染了一条河——为了保持这个假设，请理解，我绝不会污染河流，Rose，你必须明白。我只是把它存起来，留待将来你污染河流时我起诉你用。好的。好的。
I would never pollute a river. But if I were to pollute a river in Inoclin and the effects of that pollution were felt in LA or San Diego or even Mexico, if Mexico had an environmental person had law, could I be sued by a river like in another country? Yeah, it's a really good question. The true answer is no one knows, right? Like this has not been a thing that anyone has tried. I think probably you wouldn't be sued by a river
我绝不会污染河流。但如果我在奥克兰污染了一条河，而这种污染的影响在洛杉矶、圣地亚哥甚至墨西哥被感受到，如果墨西哥有环境法人法，我会被另一个国家的河流起诉吗？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。真实的答案是没人知道，对吧？因为这还不是任何人尝试过的事情。我想你可能不会被
from Mexico at least right now, just because suing somebody from another country opens up a whole other can of worms. But if San Diego had an environmental person had law and they could trace the damage that was done to the river back to you up here in Oakland, then theoretically, yes, because you are in the same state, it is possible that you could be sued to the river back to you up here in Oakland, then theoretically yes, because you are in the same state. It is possible that you could be sued by the river in San Diego.
来自墨西哥的河流起诉，至少现在不会，仅仅是因为起诉另一个国家的人会引发一系列其他麻烦。但如果圣地亚哥有环境法人法，并且他们能追踪到对河流的损害并追溯到你这里，在奥克兰，那么理论上，是的，因为你们在同一个州，你有可能被圣地亚哥的河流起诉。
And I actually asked Thomas Lindsay about this too, because I'm sort of obsessed with this river question. And the answer is, is that these laws have a, what we refer to as an extra jurisdictional component, which is that if you're recognizing the right of the river to exist, that anything happening upstream from the river that's violating the rights as that river flows through that particular municipality is actionable, which means you can bring a lawsuit against whoever's interfering with the rights by operating upstream. This is a way of applying environmental law in a small place that can have exceptional application
我实际上也问过 Thomas Lindsay 这个问题，因为我有点沉迷于这个河流问题。答案是，这些法律有一个我们称之为“域外管辖”的组成部分，也就是说，如果你承认河流的生存权，那么在河流流经该特定城市时，任何在上游发生的违反权利的行为都是可诉的，这意味着你可以对任何通过在上游作业而干扰这些权利的人提起诉讼。这是一种在小地方应用环境法的方法，可以产生特殊的应用，
outside of that, especially when you're dealing with rivers or other ecosystems that, of course, don't respect municipal boundaries. So I, part of the reason I like the river example and I think about it all the time is because it does help show something that I got to thinking about a lot when working on this episode, which is that when you really start to play out some of these future scenarios and you really start to fully buy into this idea and the applications, you start to see that this strategy can get a little bit bananas. Well please explain more. Sure, so there is a case in India that I think kind of illustrates what I'm talking about. So in 2017, a court in Uttarakhand granted personhood
特别是在处理河流或其他当然不尊重市政边界的生态系统时。所以我喜欢河流这个例子的部分原因，也是我一直在思考的原因，是因为它确实有助于展示我在制作这一集时思考很多的事情，那就是当你真正开始推演这些未来场景，并真正开始完全接受这个想法及其应用时，你会发现这个策略可能会变得有点疯狂。好吧，请多解释一下。当然，印度有一个案例，我认为它说明了我所说的内容。2017 年，北阿坎德邦的一家法院授予了
to the Ganges and Yamuna rivers. Now, the state immediately appealed and ultimately the rivers were stripped of the rights they had just been given before it actually made any difference at all. But the thing that is interesting about this is that the issue in this case seemed to not only be about the geographical span of these rivers, right? They're quite long. But also about what it means to actually say that these rivers are legal persons. So having the rights of a person means being protected from harm, right? But it also means that you can be held accountable
恒河和亚穆纳河法人资格。现在，该邦立即上诉，最终这些河流在还没产生任何实际影响之前，就被剥夺了刚刚获得的权利。但有趣的是，这个案件的问题似乎不仅在于这些河流的地理跨度，对吧？它们很长。而且还在于真正说这些河流是“法律意义上的人”意味着什么。拥有人的权利意味着受到保护免受伤害，对吧？但也意味着你可能要为
for the harm that you cause. So you can't punch me and I also can't punch you back speaking of things that we would never do, like political river. And in this case in India, there actually was a question about whether or not the river could be held accountable for its actions. So in their appeal, the government asked whether people could sue for any damages that the river caused. Right.
你造成的伤害承担责任。所以你不能打我，我也不能打你——说到我们永远不会做的事情，比如政治河流。在印度的这个案例中，确实存在一个关于河流是否能为其行为负责的问题。因此，在他们的上诉中，政府询问人们是否可以就河流造成的任何损害提起诉讼。没错。
Okay, so like if the river flooded and destroyed my house, you know, it could theoretically be responsible if it was a person. Yes. And this was a concern that was cited in the appeal by the government saying, like, we can't open this can of worms because like what happens if people sue the river back? Right. Because like, how do you hold a river accountable? Right. I genuinely don't know. And I think it would probably involve the state just having to pay for it, right? If the state is representing the river, but like again, no one knows what that would look like.
好吧，所以如果河流泛滥摧毁了我的房子，你知道，如果它是一个人，理论上它可能要负责。是的。这是政府在上诉中提到的一个担忧，说，我们不能打开这个潘多拉魔盒，因为如果人们反过来起诉河流怎么办？对吧。因为，你怎么让一条河流负责？对吧。我真的不知道。我想这可能涉及国家必须为此买单，对吧？如果国家代表河流，但同样，没人知道那会是什么样子。
So I will say advocates for environmental personhood say that they're not really actually arguing that rivers should be treated exactly like people. I think they all kind of recognize that that way madness lies. But sometimes they will use the term legal naturehood instead of legal personhood, which is, you know, legal people love to coin new words for things. I don't know what that means necessarily, right? It still opens up this question of like which rights nature does get and which ones it doesn't get.
所以我得说，环境法人资格的倡导者们说，他们实际上并不是真的在争论河流应该被完全像人一样对待。我想他们都意识到那条路是疯狂的。但有时他们会使用“法律自然权”（legal naturehood）这个词，而不是“法律人格”（legal personhood），你知道，法律界人士喜欢为事物创造新词。我不知道这必然意味着什么，对吧？它仍然引出了一个问题，即自然究竟获得哪些权利，哪些权利得不到。
Right. But giving it a new name, at least sort of sidesteps the asymmetry of the term personhood, but it's still sort of confounding, thought exercise. Again, when we talked about polluting the river in Oakland, again, something we would never do, and it reaching San Diego to cause harm. Historically, San Diego has always had the right to sue somebody upriver for causing harm, right? Like, why do we need a new law when you do have these other enforcement mechanisms already? You know, I am not a lawyer, but I think that what Frank and Thomas would argue is that, yeah, we have all of these ways of suing, but none of them work to protect the river. And so why not try this other way? And like, I will be honest that to me philosophically the idea of environmental personhood of rights of nature, it does appeal to me, right? Like this idea
没错。但给它起个新名字，至少在某种程度上避开了“人格”一词的不对称性，但这仍然是一个令人困惑的思想实验。再次回到我们在奥克兰污染河流——再次强调，我们绝不会这样做——并导致圣地亚哥受损的问题。从历史上看，圣地亚哥一直有权起诉上游造成损害的人，对吧？那么，当你们已经有了这些其他执法机制时，为什么还需要一部新法律呢？你知道，我不是律师，但我认为 Frank 和 Thomas 会争辩说，是的，我们有所有这些起诉方式，但没有一种能保护河流。所以为什么不试试这种方法呢？而且，老实说，从哲学上讲，环境人格或自然权利的想法确实吸引我，对吧？这种想法
that we should respect these places, right? That they're living entities that we should think about them as truly alive. I also buy into the idea that the current environmental regulations are not working, right? That the system we have is not working. But at the same time, when you start to look into these specific examples, like Ken the River sue you back, what does this really mean? I can't help but feeling like we're sort of trying
即我们应该尊重这些地方，对吧？它们是活生生的实体，我们应该把它们视为真正有生命的。我也认同目前的各种环境法规不起作用的观点，对吧？我们现有的系统不起作用。但与此同时，当你开始研究这些具体的例子时，比如河流能反过来起诉你吗？这到底意味着什么？我不禁觉得我们是在试图
to force a square peg into a round hole of sort of an indigenous thought system into the US legal system. And those are just kind of not fundamentally the same things. And I did ask Thomas about this. We talked about it a lot actually. And when I first asked him, he was basically like, yeah, like obviously there's two different world views there.
把方钉强行塞进圆孔，将某种原住民思想体系强行塞进美国法律体系。它们在根本上并不是同一回事。我确实问过 Thomas 这个问题。我们实际上谈论了很多。当我第一次问他时，他基本上说，是的，显然那里有两种不同的世界观。
One which is proven to be incredibly destructive, almost world destructive, globally destructive. And another one that sees nature in a much different light in which humans need to live in some kind of harmony or compatibility with nature rather than trying to climb on top of it and stretch it on a rack and torture it in a medieval torture device. Thomas does love backflow about the torture device, which I also love. It doesn't mean it's where it's I like them. No, yeah, exactly. And maybe that's fine, right? Maybe it doesn't matter if we are trying to force this square peg into a round hole if it gets results, right?
一种已被证明具有极大的破坏性，几乎是世界性的、全球性的破坏。另一种则以完全不同的眼光看待自然，人类需要在某种和谐或兼容的状态下与自然共存，而不是试图爬到它上面，把它拉到架子上，用中世纪的酷刑装置折磨它。Thomas 确实喜欢谈论酷刑装置，我也很喜欢。这并不意味着它很糟糕，我喜欢它们。不，是的，完全正确。也许这没关系，对吧？也许如果我们试图把这个方钉塞进圆孔，只要能产生结果，这并不重要，对吧？
Like, it's not as though we just have a ton of time to sit around and do this perfectly given the state of the environment right now. But it is sort of a strategy that really pushes us to kind of be, I think, okay, with the absurdity of the law in the name of an outcome. Yeah. I mean, this was kind of what Frank was getting out of the piece about how dumb, lock and big. Yeah, exactly.
就像，鉴于目前的环境状况，我们并没有大量的时间坐在这里完美地完成这件事。但这确实是一种策略，我认为它确实推动我们去接受法律的荒谬性，以换取某种结果。是的。我的意思是，这正是 Frank 在文章中提到的关于“愚蠢、锁定和巨大”的内容。是的，完全正确。
Because you really can use it in all kinds of different ways. I mean, it really is conflicting logic arguments and you can have logic arguments all day long and never be done. Yeah. And like right now, the weird and silly way that nature laws work, work in favor of people who are generally polluting. So like, why not do it the opposite way? Why not make it work in favor of nature? Totally fair. And I think that, you know, Frank and Thomas see this gap and they are really trying to make something work now while also thinking bigger pictures. So you can do both, right?
因为你确实可以用各种不同的方式使用它。我的意思是，这确实是相互冲突的逻辑论点，你可以整天争论逻辑，永远没完没了。是的。而且就像现在，自然法律那种奇怪而愚蠢的运作方式，有利于那些通常在污染的人。所以，为什么不反其道而行之呢？为什么不让它有利于自然呢？完全公平。而且我认为，Frank 和 Thomas 看到了这个差距，他们确实在努力让某些事情现在就起作用，同时也着眼于更大的图景。所以你可以两者兼顾，对吧？
You can do your like weird little law fiddling and also be trying to imagine a system that is a little bit more holistic. What we're talking about is a complete overhaul here. This is just the beginning of seeing the world in a different way because if there's no, there's no better well-trot concept in the Western system of law than the one in which nature is property. It's basically the building block for everything in a western culture, a western civilization. Yeah, and he's talking about nature not being property. So it's just a complete overall
你可以进行你那种奇怪的小法律修补，同时也试图构想一个更全面的系统。我们在这里谈论的是彻底的改革。这只是以不同方式看待世界的开始，因为在西方法律体系中，没有比“自然是财产”这一概念更根深蒂固的了。它基本上是西方文化、西方文明中一切事物的基石。是的，他谈论的是自然不是财产。所以这只是一个彻底的改革
of Western civilization as we know it. Yeah, I mean, like, I'll just pencil it in. I feel like I'm probably free Wednesday. I don't know what you're doing. You know, we'll just work on it. Just knock it out on the Zoom. Yeah, yeah, yeah, really, really epic Zoom. But in, like, it all seriously is like,
我们所知的西方文明。是的，我的意思是，我会把它记下来。我觉得我周三可能有空。我不知道你在做什么。你知道，我们只是处理它。在 Zoom 上把它搞定。是的，是的，是的，非常非常史诗般的 Zoom。但认真地说，就像，
actually think that is why I got really interested in this idea in the first place. And like why I wanted to explore these cases and I think why we keep talking about this, right? I spend a lot of time on Flash Forward, my podcast thinking about what might move us to a better future. And when you look at history as you do on this show all the time and there's lots of episodes that you can point to that talk about this kind of thing. You realize that often it's these weird little strategies
实际上我认为这就是我最初对这个想法产生浓厚兴趣的原因。也是为什么我想探索这些案例，以及我认为为什么我们一直在谈论这个的原因，对吧？我在我的播客《Flash Forward》上花了很多时间思考什么能推动我们走向更好的未来。当你像在这个节目中一直做的那样审视历史时，有很多集节目可以指出这种事情。你会意识到，通常是这些奇怪的小策略，
that no one is expecting that kind of make a huge difference because they come out of left field and do ask people to think about the world differently. So if a river being able to sue you, Roman, for your pollution that you will never do, if that's what gets us to a better place and saving the environment, I'm for it, I think. Yeah, yeah. Well, it's really fascinating stuff. I've loved watching this story come together. It's so much fun to think about. So thank you so much for
没人预料到，它们产生巨大的差异，因为它们出其不意，确实要求人们以不同的方式思考世界。所以，如果一条河流能够起诉你，Roman，因为你永远不会做的污染，如果这就是让我们到达更好地方并拯救环境的方法，我想我支持它。是的，是的。嗯，这真是令人着迷的事情。我很高兴看到这个故事汇集在一起。思考它真是太有趣了。所以非常感谢你
bringing it to us and doing this with us. I appreciate it. Thanks. Thanks for having me. This has been very, very fun. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Rose Evelith and Ozzie Linus Goodman. It was edited by Delaney Hall, fact-checking by Graham Haysha, mixed in tech production by Amida Ganatra, music by our director of sound, Swan Rihau. Special thanks this week to Leah Lem, Philomena Quebec, Teresa Vicente Jimenez, Dan Roberts, Anteshea Hart. Rose and Ozzie make a fantastic podcast called Flash Forward. Another version of this story will be airing on Flash Forward and it will explore a number
把它带给我们并和我们一起做这件事。我很感激。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。这非常非常有趣。《99% Invisible》本周由 Rose Evelith 和 Ozzie Linus Goodman 制作。由 Delaney Hall 编辑，Graham Haysha 核实事实，Amida Ganatra 负责混音和技术制作，音乐由我们的声音总监 Swan Rihau 创作。本周特别感谢 Leah Lem、Philomena Quebec、Teresa Vicente Jimenez、Dan Roberts、Anteshea Hart。Rose 和 Ozzie 制作了一个很棒的播客叫《Flash Forward》。这个故事的另一个版本将在《Flash Forward》上播出，它将探索许多
of other rights of nature cases and other related ideas. Please check it out. 99% Invisible's Executive Producer is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colstead is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Lashmodon, Jason De Leon, Sophia Klaathster, and me Roman Mars. 99% of visible is part of the Stitcher and Series XM Podcast family. Now, it had quartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and
其他自然权利案例和其他相关想法。请去看看。《99% Invisible》的执行制片人是 Delaney Hall。Kurt Colstead 是我们的数字总监。团队其他成员包括 Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Leigh、Joe Rosenberg、Chris Barube、Christopher Johnson、Lashmodon、Jason De Leon、Sophia Klaathster，以及我 Roman Mars。《99% Invisible》是 Stitcher 和 Series XM 播客家族的一部分。现在，它位于 Pandora 大楼北侧六个街区。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并
join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99 PI org. We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99 PI at 99p.org. Thanks again to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for their underwriting supports of this special episode. Be sure to check out each episode in this four-part series, The Future of Data Tata. And if you have a hunch about what it will take to build an equitable future, share it at shareyourhunch.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars，在 @99PIorg 上关注节目。我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有账号。你可以在 99p.org 找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及《99% Invisible》的每一集往期节目。再次感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会对本特别节目的承保支持。请务必查看本四集系列节目《数据的未来》中的每一集。如果你对构建公平未来需要什么有预感，请在 shareyourhunch.org 分享。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。